so one of the big trends in 2017 at CES
is that we're going to see Amazon Alexis
voice assistant on more and more
products and one of them which is really
compelling is the LG hub bot it's
available in two sizes the big one and
the small one obviously the big one has
a bigger screen it also has more
powerful speakers but the internals are
similar there's no price availability
just yet but some of the advantages it
has over Alexa or something like the
Google home voice assistant is that we
can customize what you call this thing
right now it's set up to respond to hub
bot so you can ask you pup I'd play my
favorite song and that sort of kicks it
off and makes it start dancing so
there's some cute little animations to
it the good thing too is that LG support
serve an open platform in terms of
support so it's not just going to work
without G products and they said that
partnered with both Amazon and Google to
ensure that it can control your entire
smart home so the LG hub bought a little
more cute animated than the Amazon Alexa
devices that you're used to and we're
sure to see a lot more of this kind of
stuff than coming here